[Music]
in Santa's special snow news special
snow hae-bin
light a Colombian government agency
threatened to sue Walmart over a funny
Christmas sweater oh okay yeah just
lines a coke on the sweater and Santa's
like probably like all over his no yeah
yeah which one American Walmart Canada
Oh Canadian
why Colombia there's no Colombian flag
there's no tell you because of the
product description exactly Ryan the
frightened knows it's a Colombian Santa
Claus the description it says the
country of Colombia is suing ya know you
could do that the National Agency for
the legal defense of the states but I
think the countries can sue because like
let's say if like something happened in
war or whatever like and you could come
back like I think like those a huge
thing that happened because America used
Agent Orange in Vietnam yeah I thought
like countries could sue each other I
didn't know like countries can sue at
Pep Boys yeah they're suing Walmart and
the US and the US government and
demanded the u.s. Channel I read the US
chain which is Walmart Oh to indemnify
Colombia for the damage caused by
listing the sweater so let me read to
you this would you what damage was
caused like when they have to make right
with their wrongs make right looking
indemnified identify what about just
make a wrong right yeah right so the
actual definition is to compensate
someone for harm or loss yeah but like
how are they gonna prove how much how
much did you did the cow into the
country lose let me tell you the
description so it says we all know how
snow works it's white powdery and the
best snow comes straight from South
America
that's bad news for jolly old Saint Nick
who lives far away in the North Pole
that's why Santa really likes to savor
the moment when he gets his hands on
some quality great a Colombian snow
that's what the description read the
[ __ ] dumbasses what do they I want it
I want the sweater even more they sold
it in the wrong workplace all there you
don't sell it's a Walmart I have no idea
do they have mountain ranges okay man
you know it's mr. sweater now I would
expect to see this in something like
Spencer's or something like Sameer like
gift store so it's like this the sweater
isn't the crazy part the fact that
Walmart hadn't listed on their side it
also looks like something James Cage
white made he's got some dope merch man
I'm trying to get him to come to America
he says that he only feels safe with
staying with fans that are families and
they have kids well you stay with us you
actually can't stay with you guys no no
no he got apparently you guys have a kid
it'll make him feel safe you'll stay
with me I begged him have you seen his
recent photo he's like he's took a photo
for like this and like this and he goes
DC's me pretending to fly a jet plane
and a jet Lamborghini that's what I want
him around myself and I was like no no
you like the same mental capacity age
right
well I'm just basing it off of that
all right so that's when Walmart said in
a statement these sweaters sold by a
third party seller on Walmart CA do not
represent Walmart's values and have no
place on our website we apologize for
any unintended offence this may have
caused
and so Colombian officials they were
still unsatisfied they said the Walmart
sweater is an offense to the country it
generates damage to to the legal
products of Colombia and damage to the
country's reputation
although Walmart apologized the damage
was done who do they think they are
though but besides coffee and cult this
guy JK news are the only two things stay
away from that now cuz that has been the
stereotype for [ __ ] Becky
we're known just for coffee we don't
want to be known for coke we want to be
known for hookers and the premium
hookers like not that kind of [ __ ] let
it host wetters let it go how hard the
only other thing I know about Colombia
and this is wrong but see 100% Colombia
oh no they're like Sakura from there
that's the only heavily good chocolate
from there - I bet she was Mexican you
oh she yeah that's where a weird voice
comes from try to like see cuz I don't
like come on Vince back at the fire
[Laughter]
like that warbly kind of yeah I think
her dance moves are a mix between the
two Lebanese belly dancer and Colombian
hooker the good mix yeah I want to know
what kind of like monetary damage that I
think they're entitled to you have to
prove you have to prove the like oh we
lost like a thousand dollars because you
know whatever so what do they ask if
we're ready actionable in court yet the
best what do you want out of this like
just want to be like a while back I
guess so they I don't know
the monetary like value or like how much
but they're saying that in addition to
monetary damages they are saying that
couple three u.s. passports for every
one wasn't the sweater sold in Canada it
was Walmart Canada's website Oh sold by
a third party
but because Walmart is a us-based
company and they're suing yeah us-based
couple and then they're saying that
Columbia will demand that Walmart
promotes legal Colombian products and
slightly legal cocaine okay and spend
ten times the amount invested in
advertising cocaine related project
products ten times the amount of home
what is that really so uh countries that
they want to clean up and it's like bro
you you don't know what you're known for
yet you're working so hard but you
that's Pablo is a big-name man Pablo
Pablo's legacy goes beyond Colombia yeah
people know Pablo but they don't know
Colombia yeah and when I think Colombia
they go cocaine so they're saying that
the funds that they would receive would
be donated to foundations that support
the families of members of the police
and military forces who were killed or
wounded fighting drug trafficking then
continue saying Colombia must be
respected what will what will the family
of a person who died in the fight
against drug traffic
can feel when a firm like Walmart
promotes a bag of cocaine from Colombia
to joke yeah I like how that they're
going after Walmart because it's like
not the company who actually listed and
made this sweater oh yeah exactly it's
just like so it's just like a money grab
at the end of the day alright because
we're just trying to get a go after
whoever's got the deeper pockets and the
those people's families I don't think
that going all if the us just go to
Walmart is this you can generally far
they have they have actual snow but I
get it cuz it's a cocaine joke at
Columbia government met a Canadian none
of them are gonna be wearing that
sweater they're nice people trying to
cool who would wear that I think that's
a bad one it it's a Canadian team yeah
Americans bombed from can go to Canada
they're buying it
American tour is the Dare right that's
hilarious
yeah no the Walmart keeps getting in
trouble because they keep selling
inappropriate things only alright what
was the one they were selling so another
one that they mentioned here is last
year they had a STONER for a buyer a
STONER no so like the person that's
buying products for a Walmart it's
probably a STONER
I don't like that'll sell good this is
even Walmart though this is like cuz
then this is like it's like Amazon how
you have like 30 so even a buyer it's
just some oh it's probably it's probably
still stoned ass dude that's like
representative like filtering through
shake they're the ones that are keep
getting in trouble like for example oh
wait it's that's how it works like like
eBay
the century of the [ __ ] though the
Walmart websites like that goes oh I'm
searching for a century a wave master
bag it's one of those punching bags
filled with water yeah and then when I
googled it it took me to Walmart I'm
gonna understand this at Walmart but no
searching around oh wait what kind of is
like act like yeah they're trying to be
like that yeah oh that makes sense how
these products can leak onto their side
yeah so don't like like yeah people the
guy know that I don't know what the
liability is I think it's like YouTube
as well where YouTube isn't take
responsibility for any like one video
but they're like well we have this
platform that people can do that on I'm
in that gray area - like where amazon
has third party and now walmart has a
third party stuff like I don't know yeah
I don't know like if it's my company's
name being used in all these like really
bad cases I would [ __ ] do something
about it because this one shirt
it had impeach 45 which is a reference
to Trump the 45th President of the
United States t-shirt sold and Walmart's
US market place and then there was this
other one that in 2017 Walmart
apologized for a third-party sellers
online ad which containing racial slur
well was it the listing of a British
company that sold hair products tailored
to black people they that listing was
for a whip cat wig cap in the color and
word brown took it out I don't know I
mean they're both bad but yeah I just
want to know what they do my mind
someone you know even in Britain know
it's just like yes this is cool 70s out
oh my god but what if they thought it
was negative but like I mean that's how
it was a little brown yeah yes Taylor
did like the Oz word and then another
thing with that the company had to
apologize for a misplaced back to school
sign that was placed over a gun display
superhero-themed marketing campaign that
read owned the school year like a hero
the school oh this is just like really
unfortunate kind of coincidence yeah
your store has too many departments yeah
and they're all overlapping cubes and
cribs and guns I don't know it's there's
a lot of mistakes yeah it's easy it's
not pretty funny though
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]